[Applause]
[Music]
that's Grammy winning guitarist Peter
Frampton with one of his big hits do you
feel like we do Frampton's been touring
now for 50 years and his 1976 album
Frampton Comes Alive remains one of the
best-selling live albums of all time but
yesterday the 68 year old singer
announced his next tour will be his last
[Music]
in his Nashville studio Peter Frampton
has been furiously recording music
between October and two days ago we've
done like 33 new tracks
I just want to record as much as I can
you know now for all these reasons the
main reason which the musician spoke
about for the first time in our
interview a degenerative muscular
disease IBM inclusion body myositis
which is what I have inclusion body
myositis is a rare and incurable
inflammatory condition which causes
muscles to weaken slowly what exactly
have you felt going upstairs and
downstairs is the hardest thing for me
I'm going to have to get a cane and then
the other thing I noticed I can't put
things up over my head Frampton was
diagnosed about three and a half years
ago after a fall on stage the disease
progressed gradually but in September
October when I came off tour I noticed a
it sped up a little bit
ya know how did you notice that I went
on vacation with my daughter Mia to Maui
and I fell on a boat and it was a pretty
bad fall that's when he began to make
plans to leave the road what will happen
unfortunately is that it affects the the
finger flexors so for a guitar player
it's not very good have you felt that
already yes
but I'm able to play great right now in
a year's time maybe not so good I'm a
perfectionist you know and I do not want
to go out there and feel like oh I can't
this isn't good
yeah you know I that would be you know a
nightmare for me you know break your
heart absolutely because it's my passion
I've been playing guitar for 60 years
started when I was 8 and now I'm 68 so
I've had a very good run a run that
started in the 1960s as a teen idol in
England with the group the heard
Frampton then co-founded humble pie a
band that took him onto the British
charts but his breakthrough would come
as a solo artist with his live album
Frampton Comes Alive released in 1976 it
spent 10 weeks at number one the massive
platinum plaque commemorating its sales
more than 18 million records hung and
Frampton's death when I visited him for
CBS Sunday morning in 2012 it's almost
like it's not me really yeah it's like
it says it's another lifetime but but
that's hanging in your house I know it's
his that guy after that Frampton seemed
to lose his way his sales slid it was
almost a decade before he got his career
back on course with help from a friend
he'd known since grade school
is this you on tour with Bowie that's
yeah that was the that was the gossip I
do tour in 1987 David Bowie asked him to
tour with him as his lead guitarist that
comeback has informed Frampton's battle
with the IBM disease but it can't be
easy to confront something like this no
it's it's not obviously but I'm thinking
of all the times in my my life that I
have something devastating has happened
to my career or and my family or me
I've brushed myself off got myself up
and changed directions when you told
your kids what did your kids say to you
they were devastated you know but I said
look it's not life-threatening it's it's
life-changing Oh they've been phenomenal
every one every one of my ex-wives I
have been wonderful I have to say even
they've been sympathetic yes so I thank
them daily
Frampton will go back on the road in the
summer I imagine it's gonna be a pretty
emotional tour for you I would think so
we're going to be playing the forum and
we're going to be playing Madison Square
Garden and I have played those in many
many years and my kids are going to be
there yes it'll be a sad occasion when
the last date happens but a [ __ ] and
one two yes
I know that I will be at the top of my
game for this tour and I will make it
through this and people won't be saying
oh you know he can't play as good I can
you know but we just don't know for how
long
so Frampton is working feverishly in his
studio
[Music]
while participating in a new drug trial
at Johns Hopkins where a team of doctors
has been coordinating his treatment a
lot of farewell tours aren't exactly
farewells
I think the who have done 27 farewell to
us now if this is the farewell tour then
maybe if the drug trial works there'll
be the miracle too
I mean I wish but I'm realistic too so
that's why we're really this is really
is the farewell tour
I'm so glad he's getting a victory lap
there's so many people that have
memories associated with his music what
he's brought to so many people's lives
and when you hear him say when you
talked about his kids saying it's not
life-threatening it's life-changing if
half the battle in dealing with a
disease like this is that mental
attitude as he goes forward that has to
be such a key knowing that then it just
as a change I met him in the 1990s
incredibly generous down-to-earth but it
struck me how open he was with you yes
well he's been keeping this to himself
for three and a half years I know how
hard it was to finally talk about it and
I and I appreciate that he trusted us to
do it trusted you Anthony Mason trusted
you